Sorry everyone, there's science here and you're not gonna like it.
Some people are much more attractive to those annoying flying little mosquitoes,...
...and a lot of it comes down to carbon dioxide.
Some people actually give off more CO2 than others and mosquitoes are huge fans.
In fact, female mosquitoes have nerve cells with special receptors just to detect CO2.
Larger people, hyperactive people and people who have just exercised...
...all give off more CO2 than average.
Unfortunately, it's not just CO2 to blame.
Research has shown mosquitoes also really dig type O blood.
They're significantly more likely to land on them as people with type A blood.
So, the idea that some people have sweet blood...
...may actually not be that far off.